en 2022 60000 personnes sont décédées en
Europe à cause des chaleurs extrêmes 60
000 personnes un nombre inconcevable et
même avec des températures excessives
les personnes directement exposées aux
canicules sont toujours au travail
ouvrier du bâtiment agriculteurs
éboueurs entre centaines d'autres
activités il reste toujours mobilisés
pour le bon fonctionnement de notre
société vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Commissaire nous vivons une époque où
les températures augmentent où les
vagues de chaleur deviennent de plus en
plus extrêmes rendant le travail
toujours plus difficile notamment à
l'extérieur notamment pour les
travailleurs manuels notamment pour ceux
occupants des emplois précaires notre
responsabilité reste de veiller à ce
qu'ils soient tous en sécurité quel que
soit les conditions climatiques et face
à cette situation inédite il nous faut
mettre en place de nouvelles règles il
nous faut aménager les conditions de
travail que ce soit avec des équipements
de protection
avec des infrastructures adaptées ou
même avec des mesures d'urgence la
protection des travailleurs n'est que la
face immergée de l'iceberg le sujet
demeure toujours la protection de
l'environnement elle doit aller de pair
avec la lutte contre changement
climatique elle doit aller de pair avec
notre engagement dans le pacte vert elle
doit aller de pair avec notre engagement
justice social je vous remercie